on passe à notre second degré qui ça va
se rejoindre sur certains thèmes qui
nous plonge dans l'actualité politique
de deux grands pays européens la Suède
et l'Italie confrontés à une forte
poussée électorale de l'extrême droite
en Suède la première ministre à
démissionné le parti nationaliste va
peser sur le destin du pays civil de la
lettre
la remise à démission ce matin Magdalena
Anderson chef de fil de la gauche
suédoise quitte son poste de première
ministre après sa courte défaite au
législatives
173 voix contre 166 elle a été battue
par une coalition inédite emmenée par
les trois parties de droite mais aussi
pour la première fois par l'extrême
droite un bouleversement d'autant plus
important que le parti nationaliste de
Jimmy akeson est arrivé en tête de sa
coalition avec 20% des voix il est temps
de commencer à reconstruire la sécurité
la prospérité la cohésion il est temps
de faire passer la Suède en premier
héritier d'un groupe néo-nazis fondé à
la fin des années 80 le parti
nationaliste a fait campagne autour de
l'Immigration et de l'insécurité
des thèmes qui ont particulièrement
trouvé de l'écho dans les petites villes
du sud du pays où il est arrivé en tête
une percée électorale qui fait réagir
dans les rues de Stockholm
il se présente en faisant peur aux gens
en disant que ce n'est pas sûr de vivre
en Suède
mais cela ne concerne qu'un ou deux pour
cent des Suédois
ça fait peur c'est étrange
l'idiocracie gagner du terrain un peu
partout
[Musique]
le leader démodéré qui doit tenter de
former un gouvernement un numéro
d'équilibriste pour cet ancien gymnaste
je commence maintenant le travail pour
former un gouvernement efficace un
gouvernement pour toute la Suède et tous
les citoyens
reste à savoir si l'extrême droite en
fera partie si les modérée leur ont
tordus la main les autres formations de
droite sont farouchements opposées à
l'entrée des nationalistes au
gouvernement
Suède l'Italie poussait de l'extrême
droite banalisation de l'extrême droite
on va en débattre tout de suite avec mes
invités Pascal Joana bonsoir bienvenue
vous êtes directrice générale de la
Fondation Robert Schuman
jacquelibéatrigible bonsoir et bienvenue
géographe directrice de la revue
Hérodote auteur de l'extrême droite en
Europe publiée aux éditions La
Découverte
Erwan Le Coeur bonsoir bienvenue vous
êtes sociologue et politologue
spécialiste de l'extrême droite laetitia
cruppa est restée à mes côtés on vient
de le voir Pascal Johanna la première
ministre sortante a reconnu sa défaite
en Suède bon il y a cette probabilité
d'une coalition qui est qui est forte
même si les peut-être que ils ne seront
pas au gouvernement mais ils vont peser
sur la ligne bref on attend encore de
voir comment ça va tourner il y a cette
question de la de la ligne rouge de la
digue est-ce que vous dites qu'elle est
en train clairement de disparaître ou de
s'effriter comment vous l'analysez alors
d'abord en Suède d'abord en Suède le
résultat est très serré bien sûr il faut
le rappeler c'est d'ailleurs on a
pendant eu trois jours une commission
électorale qui a dit je veux pas
annoncer les résultats parce que c'est
un siège c'était tellement c'était
tellement serré et vous avez en effet de
coalition il y avait une collection de
gauche une coalition de droite on va
voir l'importance des coalitions quand
on reparlera de l'Italie donc c'est en
effet toute une série de petits pas vous
avez là-dedans un parti qui est arrivé
en tête le Parti social-démocrate de la
première ministre c'est celui qui est
arrivé en tête c'est pas le Parti social
des démocrate suédois donc
ils sont arrivés deuxième et c'est là où
le c'est la signification c'est parce
que ils sont arrivés deuxième heure
qu'ils étaient troisième il y a quatre
ans
le premier parti de cette coalition de
droite voilà pour autant pour autant
alors on n'imagine pas que ça puisse
exister ailleurs c'est pas Jimmy akinson
qui va devenir le premier ministre de
Suède il n'est même pas certain qu'il y
ait des Démocrates suédois qui soient
dans le gouvernement pour autant alors
pour
[Musique]
Démocrates suédois bon donc la digue
s'effrite si je ça fait plusieurs années
qu'elle s'était fritée en Suède alors
effectivement on va détailler ça d'abord
avec vous batterie Giblin on a moi j'ai
été élevé en quelque sorte et je me suis
pro avec ce modèle
ce modèle social-démocrate des pays du
nord de l'Europe il existe plus depuis
longtemps il existe encore
le modèle social-démocrate je veux dire
il y a un parti qui était social
démocrate au pouvoir jusqu'à dimanche et
qui a ces trois sièges d'écart entre la
gauche et la droite donc on peut pas
dire et c'est le premier parti
puisqu'elle a eu 30% des voix voilà donc
on peut pas dire que la
social-démocratie a totalement
on l'imaginait pas mais aussi la
situation en Suède a changé en
particulier la situation de
l'immigration la Suède en séol of palme
en 84 qui prend une politique
extrêmement gén dans l'accueil des
réfugiés des réfugiés politiques surtout
pour la Palestine c'est ce qui a été sa
motivation il y a toujours eu des
étrangers en Suède mais il venait de
Finlande il venait de Norvège il venait
de pays où ça posait pas de gros
problèmes ce qui a posé problème n'ont
pas dans les années 80 mais c'est ce qui
a posé problème à partir du début des
années 2000 parce que ça monte quand
même depuis le début des années 2000
c'est l'arrivée d'une population
immigrée qui est devenue assez massive
rapporté à la population de la suite 10
millions d'habitants en Suède deux
millions de populations étrangères dont
dans ces deux millions un million 100 un
million 150 000 qui est d'origine hors
européenne donc Ethiopien somalien
afghan irakien syrien bien sûr parce
qu'en Syrie à partir de 2013 il a pris
cette décision très généreuse qui était
d'accorder politique permanent à tous
syriens qui arriverait en Suède avec les
avantages sociaux importants oui parce
que c'est un système protecteur il faut
le rappeler protecteurs donc ceci au
bout d'un moment aujourd'hui on évalue
soyons prudents au bout de 9 ans de
présence donc ça fait 2013 2022 si vous
faites le calcul au bout de 9 ans la
moitié des réfugiés sont au chômage de
ceux qui sont arrivés c'est énorme et à
partir de ce moment-là toute une petite
musique toute la petite discours
surtout que vous pouvez y agiter ajouter
dans certains quartiers c'est vrai une
forme d'insécurité de bataille d'organes
on va pas faire les enfants de chœur
et ceci je crois qu'il y a eu 100
policiers blessés alors à quel niveau je
peux pas vous le dire depuis le début de
l'année 2022 donc ceci suscite une
inquiét profonde sur qu'allons-nous
devenir est-ce que la Suède va rester la
Suède on était si bien si tranquille si
généreux et voilà que
on a souvent nos journalistes le
tendance à être un peu le nez dans le
guidon et à manquer un peu de recul
historique des poussées populistes ou
des poussées d'extrême droite en Suède
ou dans d'autres pays du nord de
l'Europe mais 10 restants sur la Suède
simplifions ça fait quoi ça fait combien
de décennies ça a déjà existé dans les
années 70 et 80 c'est d'ailleurs à cette
époque là qu'on a inventé plus ou moins
le terme de populisme des nantis c'est à
dire que dans certains pays dont la
Suède la Norvège les Pays-Bas et
d'autres danois Danemark il y a eu déjà
une montée du populisme de nanti qui ne
voulait pas partager ce qui a bien été
expliqué ce modèle extraordinaire le
consociationnisme des Pays-Bas bien il y
a PIM fortune qui est arrivé quasi pas
pour tout le monde c'est on s'est battu
pour des acquis sociaux on est très
généreux mais à un moment on l'est trop
et donc BIM fortune a été un des signaux
d'alarme des années 90 2000 qui a rénové
quelque chose qui existait déjà on s'en
souvient peu dans les années 70-80 déjà
à l'époque le modèle dont on parle avait
déjà été mis entre guillemets à mal
beaucoup moins qu'aujourd'hui par le
fait d'un afflu en effet d'un certain
nombre de réfugiés réfugiés des guerres
de l'époque mais à l'époque c'était des
réfugiés qui venaient plutôt de l'Est
c'était par exemple des bottes people
donc comme ils étaient anti-communiste
ça passait mieux c'était des gens qui
venaient d'autres pays en difficulté de
l'Est de l'Europe etc aujourd'hui et ça
a été assez bien rappelé nous avons une
série de crises mondiales dont la crise
climatique mais aussi les crises en
Afghanistan en Syrie en Ukraine qui ont
fait depuis une dizaine d'années des
afflux d'immigrés qui ont été très bien
accueillis en Suède au sens où la Suède
est un pays qui accueille bien comme les
Pays-Bas comme d'autres pays comme cela
et ce bon accueil à un moment donné
peut-être en effet dépassé par de
nouveaux phénomènes et notamment des
phénomènes dont on parle peu que ils
sont rarement évoqués que j'appellerais
les mafias internationales qui pullulent
sur le dos de ces migrations et qui dans
certains pays dans certains quartiers
dans certaines zones peuvent générer des
phénomènes de violence ultra d'ultra
violence que les gens voient et dont ils
ont peur et ça gênait en effet des
points d'accès pour toutes les extrêmes
que soit en Italie en France on voit à
quelle fin c'est de violence alors il y
a plusieurs fins d'abord vous avez comme
ça vient d'être dit plein de ces
étrangers qui ne sont pas intégrés qui
n'arrivent plus à être intégrés pour
tout un tas de raisons afflux problèmes
internes déjà intérieur et puis aussi
parce que un certain nombre sont
également je dirais tenu par des mafia
qui sont restés au pays on peut parler
des Arméniens on peut parler des Syriens
on peut parler des Afghans imaginons que
quand les aliments arrivent et bien il y
a une des millions de personnes qui
veulent quitter l'Afghanistan et ils se
retrouvent où ils se retrouvent là où
ils ont des contacts et donc en
Angleterre en Suède ou même en France en
Belgique ou en pays bien on va avoir des
populations qui vont se sédentariser à
des endroits en particulier qui vont et
on va avoir des sous mafia qui vont
exploiter cette main d'oeuvre absolument
captive complètement captive et là on va
avoir toutes sortes de trafic je
rappelle juste nous sommes dans un monde
où les trois marchés les plus
florissants sont le sexe la drogue et
les armes donc à partir de là vous voyez
bien que ces gens-là c'est mondial c'est
mondial et on en parle très peu c'est un
des problèmes auxquels nos pays sont
affrontés et c'est vrai que l'Europe la
Suède en premier qui était parmi les
pays les plus accueillants les plus qui
intégré le mieux et bien la Suède et
quelque part un peu aux avant-postes un
peu comme l'Italie dans un autre style
l'Italie est aux avant-poste parce que
les immigrés débarquent sur les plages
la Suède c'est l'endroit où ils arrivent
et où quelque part c'était un eldorado
une fois qu'on était intégré en Suède on
pouvait refaire sa vie quand on est plus
intégré en Suède alors en effet il y a
des phénomènes que les Suédois ne
supportent pas parce qu'ils ont un pays
qui est beaucoup plus tranquille
beaucoup plus pacifié beaucoup plus où
on débat où on discute et où le modèle
social démocrate et d'une certaine façon
en train en effet d'être non pas mis en
pièces mais d'imploser de l'Intérieur à
cause de ses formes de violence visible
de plus en plus les derniers points je
me permets quand même les médias les
médias privés que ce soit en Angleterre
dans tous ces pays il y a l'explosion
des médias privés qui sont tenus par des
milliardaires et qui pullulent et qui se
nourrissent aussi de ces Unis
je parlais de l'Europe
alors je dis cela parce qu'on parle de
l'Italie et le début de tout ça c'est
quand même perdu ce que nous on en
parlera tout à l'heure on en parlera
tout à l'heure en détail de l'Italie
allez-y rapidement il y a beaucoup de
d'éléments des questions de l'Islam il y
a la question du statut de la femme or
en Suède dans les pays scandinaves
l'égalité homme-femme était quand même
une revendication de très long terme ils
sont bien plus en avance que nous
là-dessus et vraiment le statut des
femmes
musulmanes voilées
visibles un rapport aux femmes dérange
profondément cette société égalitaire
homme-femme il faut il faut pas le
négliger ce facteur là qui est beaucoup
plus puissant que chez nous une réaction
celle de Gérard Larcher ce matin le
président du Sénat la Suède et l'Italie
paye la crise de résultats notamment sur
la question de l'immigration on est en
plein sur dans le thème de notre débat
il appartient à notre pays d'en tirer
les enseignements évidemment il ramène
ça à la à l'actualité politique
française
Pascal Johanna je reste sur le modèle
suédois est-ce que a rendu les Suédois
je vous avais employé tout à l'heure un
peu angélique face à cette
montée de l'immigration et des problèmes
liés à l'immigration notamment à
l'immigration musulmane est-ce que ça
leur a donné un temps de retard par
rapport à la capacité à voir venir cette
crise dont on parle aujourd'hui alors
ils sont toujours été accueillants je
vais pas redire ce que vous avez dit
maintenant parce qu'en effet c'est une
terre d'accueil on a beaucoup dans ce
souvient qu'il y a des personnes qui ont
trouvé refuge trouver refuge en Suède
qui était un pays neutre je le rappelle
aussi donc ça bien sûr c'est pas c'est
pas l'anodin parce qu'en effet c'est à
ça voilà voilà et donc jusqu'à la
semaine dernière ou vu encore
juridiquement parce qu'il faut que ce
soit ratifié par l'ensemble voilà donc
allez au bout de la phrase j'ai pas
compris ce que vous dire
ils sont en processus pour entrer dans
l'OTAN d'accord et voilà allons au bout
des des phrases que parce que tout le
monde ne comprend pas ce que vous avez
en tête quand vous l'exprimez pas ils
étaient neutres ils sont encore jusqu'à
quelques semaines puisque en effet le
processus est en cours de ratification
ils vont rentrer dans le
pour d'autres raisons c'est plus pour
l'agression
ukrainienne pour la l'immigration mais
l'immigration c'est comme vous l'avez
dit c'est fait depuis longtemps mais
surtout ils ont un nouveau leader qui en
a fait alors d'abord sa feuille de route
qui a été repoussoir il y a ça aussi
c'est c'est pas le rassemblement
national alors ça ça m'intéresse
comparant un peu les gens du Front
national enfin en Suède il y a des
parties diverses et variées mais les
démocraties donc ils sont le parti
populiste ne siègent pas dans le groupe
de Marine Le Pen et de Matteo Salvini
dont on va parler tout à l'heure ici
avec les Polonais réformateurs qui sont
au pouvoir en Pologne qui s'appelle le
groupe conservateur et réformateur
européen et ou d'ailleurs
à droite conservatrice une droite
conservatrice additionnelle
traditionnelle mais où il y a aussi les
partisans de Georgia Mélanie Fratelli
d'Italia donc et donc on a bien en effet
une extrême droite où il y a marine Le
Pen Matteo Salvini mais ni les
démocraties de la ni Fratelli d'Italia
ne sont dans ce groupe et puis en effet
si on regarde les voisins qui ont eu une
expérience de groupe j'allais dire
d'extrême droite et qui les ont pris au
gouvernement ce qui n'est pas le cas
encore de la Suède mais les Vrais
Finlandais puisque les Vrais Finlandais
ils ont ils auraient au pouvoir et
quelques années c'était le deuxième
partie on les a mis au pouvoir et
qu'est-ce qui est arrivé au bout de 3
ans ils ont implosé parce qu'il y avait
ceux qui étaient je compose avec la
réalité le pragmatique et puis il y en a
d'autres qui ont dit jusqu'au bout je
reste sur la ligne etc donc si on
participe au gouvernement quand on est
un parti qui ne l'a jamais été on risque
fort d'avoir en effet des problèmes de
cohésion et d'unité parce qu'il y a la
réalité il y a le presse il y a le
principe de réalité et donc est-ce que
vous avez dit pendant la campagne vous
le faites plus parce qu'après un moment
donné mais là pour le cas des démocrates
on va voir ce qui va se passer mais pour
l'instant ils sont en dehors des trucs
mais il va bien falloir qu'il vote pour
que la majorité
modérée de droite puisse gouverner c'est
passionnant ce que vous venez de dire je
vais vous entendre là-dessus Erwan Le
coeur parce que évidemment tous les
partis politiques de droite et d'extrême
droite sont en train de regarder ce qui
se passe en Suède ou en Italie c'est pas
le même système c'est la proportionnelle
bref on peut un peu l'expliquer mais la
question derrière tout ça c'est est-ce
que la droite traditionnelle peut
revenir au pouvoir sans s'allier avec
l'extrême droite de moins en moins on a
deux phénomènes concurrents d'une part
on a en effet la montée des populismes
je dirais médiatisé médiatique et les
populismes nationalistes sur la base de
l'anti islamisme et l'anti
migrationnisme voilà on a une montée de
cela dans tout un tas de pays je dirais
même en Inde même en Inde c'est le
musulman qui est lentille hindou et les
fascistes hindous qui sont au pouvoir le
baladier pour ne pas le nommer avec
Monsieur maudit c'est contre les
musulmans qui sont les plus la plus
grande communauté musulmane du monde
quand même c'est 12% de la population
sur un milliard 400 000 ça fait du monde
et on a le Pakistan à côté donc il y a
là quelque chose qui est en train de
monter qui est ce qu'on a imaginé étant
les suites du clash des civilisations
Huntington dans les années 90 on avait
deux visions du monde il y avait la fin
de l'histoire avec Fukuyama et
Huntington avec la
le clash de civilisations c'est le clash
des civilisations qui vend le plus qui
est le plus vendeur je dirais qui est le
plus simple à comprendre mais donc il
marche le plus dans l'opinion et donc
ces droites là ces droites populistes
nationalistes je parlais de Pink fortune
qui était un des premiers on peut parler
bien sûr en Finlande il y a eu des en
Suisse en Italie tout Berlusconi en
Italie il y a quand même commencé le
populisme le plus dur Le Pen évidemment
pour nous en France bien tous ces gens
là sont en progression parce qu'ils ont
en effet à moins de leur discours sur
certains points pas surtout mais sur
certains et ils se sont focalisés sur un
point essentiel qui est d'abord l'islam
et le problème même Marine Le Pen s'y
est mis en 2008 avant il y avait pas de
problème Islam il y avait un problème
immigration avec le père Jean-Marie à
partir de 2008 c'est l'islam le problème
et ça c'est devenu européen et puis
deuxième point c'est la préférence
nationale ce que j'appelle la rénovation
de l'honneur ethnique la rénovation de
leur ethnique ça consiste à dire aux
gens vous êtes peut-être un peu bête
vous n'avez pas fait beaucoup d'études
vous ne pourrez pas vite vous êtes pas
beau vous êtes pas très les gens mais au
moins vous êtes né ici vous avez droit à
quelque chose que ces immigrés n'ont pas
le droit de demander à votre place et ça
cette fameux populisme nationaliste des
années 70-80 et qui aujourd'hui connaît
un regain extrêmement fort de de force
et d'attrait pour toute une partie de la
population qui se sont abandonnés par
les institutions l'église l'école l'État
et par les partis politiques
traditionnelles qui quand même
s'effondrent là on servent à être
expliqué très bien si le parti des
nouveaux démocrates qui sont en fait un
parti fondé par des néonazis faut pas se
leurrer au départ c'est des néonazis ils
ont édulcorer le discours mais au départ
ce sont des néonazis s'il passe devant
dans la coalition de droite c'est parce
que les autres se sont effondrés le
parti de droite modérée est partie
libéraux qui en gros jouaient à touche
avec les sociaux-démocrates soit encore
plus bas et un peu comme en France
récemment on n'a plus de partie de
droite comme en Italie il y a plus de
partie de droite etc etc dans d'autres
pays tous les partis en Suède ont perdu
par rapport aux élections 2018 sauf les
sociaux-démocrates de la première
ministre et le parti de
l'affaiblissement des parties
traditionnelles on y consacrera quelques
minutes mais il y a donc on parlait de
la capacité
de la droite à arriver à revenir au
pouvoir avec une alliance de l'extrême
droite Laetitia c'est intéressant de
voir aussi d'analyser ça sous le prisme
du président de la République française
Emmanuel Macron parce que c'est la
hantise de son sang mandat c'est de
d'être de voir Marine Le Pen du succès
en fait alors ça c'est la communication
du gouvernement
Macron c'est un discours qui commence à
fleurir un peu partout dans les médias
on le lit dans des propos rapportés du
château pour qui oui ça a plus grande
hantise serait de laisser finalement les
clés du château à Marine Le Pen en 2027
et dans la macronie Thomas on lui a même
donné un nom à ce phénomène c'est
l'effet Obama pourquoi parce qu'après
les deux mandats du président américain
démocrates qui avaient promis de tout
révolutionner tout sur le plan sociétal
sur le plan des droits même
socio-économiques finalement à laisser
les clés de la maison blanche à Donald
Trump donc dans la bouche des
macronistes ça donne je vais vous dire à
propos un rapporté dans Le Parisien
lundi tenu par la députée Astrid
Panossian cofondatrice d'en marche
c'était lors du séminaire des cadres à
Metz et elle a répété donc on comprend
bien que c'est de la communication elle
l'a répété pour les journées
parlementaires elle dit le danger après
une réélection
favoriser un pays polarisé à la fin du
second mandat et la victoire d'un
mouvement populiste notre responsabilité
est immense et collective pour que nous
ne soyons pas les prochains Obama
européens vous y voyez une hypocrisie
pourquoi totale je dirais même du
cynisme parce que la polarisation du
pays existait déjà avant 2022 et pire
Emmanuel Macron a attisé à jouer avec le
feu déjà il a attisé le populisme en
appelant par exemple sont vraiment des
exemples concrets en appelant Éric
Zemmour après son agression en allant
voir le chantre du complotisme Didier
Raoul à Marseille en en faisant des
visites officielles et puis surtout il a
tout fait pour installer Marine Le Pen
comme sa principale
opposante au second tour donc il pensait
que comme ça sa victoire sera assurée ça
marchait Emmanuel Macron est responsable
des 89 députés RN à l'Assemblée oui on
en avait souvent parlé ici l'année
dernière d'ailleurs sur ce plateau on
l'avait dit souvent le cordon sanitaire
le Front républicain vous savez a
complètement explosé donc oui ils sont
responsables et les macronistes ont même
carrément brouillé les pistes je vous
propose courte interview vraiment un
extrait de ce qui avait déclaré
Jean-Michel Blanquer Aix ministre de
l'éducation nationale à la au soir de sa
défaite après le premier tour des
élections législatives tendaient
l'oreille je le dis très solennellement
l'extrême gauche est un danger aussi
important que l'extrême droite
aujourd'hui je le vis dans ma chair
depuis non seulement début de cette
campagne mais depuis cinq années
maintenant il y a une volonté de
détruire et il y a un danger d'extrême
gauche comme de l'extrême droite qui
s'appelle hyper inflation chômage et
menaces sur la démocratie et ça ça a été
unique de crête pendant toute la
campagne c'est à dire qu'ils ont mis sur
le même plan le RN et LFI il me semble
que c'est politiquement complètement
abscons mais en tout cas Emmanuel Macron
oui est responsable d'une part d'avoir
rendu d'avantage crédible Marine Le Pen
d'abord institution analyser le Pen et
finalement d'avoir fait le parti
anti-système de son père de l'avoir fait
entrer dans le système c'est ce qu'ils
appellent au RN la stratégie de la
cravate donc ils ont bien compris que ça
allait leur servir et donc oui l'effet
Obama est une des hypothèses les plus
probables batterie vous êtes d'accord
avec cette analyse et parce qu'il y a
aussi une partie il y a aussi le le des
sociétés qui sont fracturées et ça ça
vraiment faire de la seule manipulation
de la part de Macron en dégustex Makina
et qui pourrait à ce moment-là c'est pas
de la manipulation c'est une de ces
responsabilités peut-être mais
pour moi celle que vous le présentez
c'est quand même un peu vous avez dit
jouer avec le feu jouer avec le feu
c'est la manipulation va avec la
responsabilité manipuler c'est aussi
avoir une un problème de responsabilité
or je ne suis pas totalement d'accord
avec vous parce qu'on ne peut pas
expliquer 89 députés ou 42% de du score
de Marine Le Pen au deuxième tour de la
présidentielle uniquement
sans problème sans difficulté bon moi je
suis originaire d'une heure de la France
c'est pour ça que j'écoute Fabien
Roussel Fabien Roussel il est très ancré
dans dans ce territoire pauvre depuis
longtemps mais c'est important parce que
si vous regardez une carte électorale
des résultats de Mélenchon Mélenchon il
fait très peu de choses dans le nord de
la France il en fait dans le sud bien
sûr il en fait dans la drogue on jouait
pas trop qu'on s'éloigne quand même de
la thématique du débat sur les examens
cette thématique là je veux dire cette
situation de de désespérance vous avez
dit quelque chose de très très juste
Herman le coeur c'est le problème de la
nation il vous reste votre nation vous
êtes pas malin vous avez pas de boulot
vous savez pas mais vous êtes vous vous
l'aviez
et pourquoi on va vers eux parce qu'ils
ont pas exacé le pouvoir donc ils ont
pas déçu
que ça va s'arranger celle de sur cette
percée de l'extrême droite en Suède et
en Italie celle 2 Laurence Boon
secrétaire d'État chargé de l'Europe
elle était sur France Inter ce matin
c'est vrai que c'est inquiétant de voir
la percée de l'extrême droite on aura
aussi les élections en Italie comme vous
savez et c'est inquiétant pourquoi parce
que ça traduit d'abord un désarroi des
électeurs qui se détournent des parties
traditionnelles pour chercher d'autres
réponses et parce que dans ce qu'on a vu
des réponses elles sont générale soit
instable un jour on est pour l'Euro un
jour on est pas pour l'Euro un jour on
soutient la Russie puis on change d'avis
donc ça a été incertitude et inquiétante
sur les sujets sociétaux aussi on le
voit le droit à des minorités le droit
les femmes le droit avortement sont
souvent remises en cause on a des
institutions européennes qui
fonctionnent donc on va travailler
ensemble on va respecter le choix des
vecteur mais c'est vrai que c'est
inquiétant alors il y a deux éléments
dans cette réaction il y a la faiblesse
des parties traditionnelles puis ensuite
l'avenir de l'Union européenne on va en
parler dans un instant de l'Union
européenne mais sur la faiblesse des
parties de gouvernement Erwan Le cœur
c'est pas un phénomène suédois c'est pas
un phénomène français c'est même pas un
phénomène européen c'est plus vaste que
ça oui c'est très vaste c'est le je
dirais que depuis la convention et la
répartition gauche droite dans une salle
au début entre les monarchistes d'un
côté et les Antilles monarchistes de
l'autre qui ont donné gauche et droite
depuis
le
début du 20e siècle on n'avait pas vu à
ce point un effondrement un effritement
de ce entre guillemets clivage qui
n'était pas un clivage qui était en
réalité une répartition dans deux camps
socio-politiques bien distincts qui
provenait de loin si on regarde en
sciences politiques ça provient des
rouges et des blancs les catholiques et
les autres ça provient de très très loin
il y a une très bonne sociologique sur
tout ça donc oui il y a un effondrement
qui est donc on en a parlé sur ce
plateau à nombreuses reprises lors des
élections la tripolarisation du champ
politique donne lieu à des
recompositions dont je suis en partie
d'accord avec ce que vous avez dit tout
à l'heure donc profite largement un
Emmanuel Macron puisque d'une certaine
façon et Monsieur Blanquer est
absolument caricatural dans sa l'analyse
sociopolitique il y a les méchants
d'extrême là il y a les méchants de
l'extrême là et nous on est le camp de
la raison le camp du bien à un moment ça
tient pas ça va finir par ne pas tenir
plus ça ne va plus te dire ça a tenu et
donc quand ça ne tient plus qu'est-ce
qu'on fait on va chez les méchants de là
ou les méchants de là et d'une certaine
façon c'est cette tripolarisation du
champ politique vous l'avez rappelé et
est en cours dans bien des pays dans le
monde elle se joue sur des modalités que
j'appelle pour ma part depuis les années
90/2 j'ai fait ma thèse sur le sujet
politique ou religieux et pas seulement
politique Trump bolsonaro et les autres
sont élus sur les modalités politico
religieuses et les démocrates en Suède
il y a aussi du politique et du
religieux là-dedans il y a aussi quelque
chose de l'ordre d'une croisade contre
quelque chose il y a aussi de l'ordre
d'un combat renouvelé et là vous avez
raison cette nation c'est pas juste une
nation c'est un combat civilisationnel
qu'ils veulent incarner et donc oui en
France comme ailleurs nous sommes à deux
doigts de et moi je suis désolé de le
dire mais c'est un peu pathétique
d'entendre une responsable dire en gros
les autres sont instables donc ne vous y
fiez pas quand même et puis sur les
droits des femmes ils sont pas très très
fort si c'est tout ce qu'on a à dire de
l'extrême droite aujourd'hui et du
problème de de l'effondrement des
parties en Suède c'est pas c'est pas ce
qu'on parle de l'Italie donc rapidement
aux Français au niveau français quand
même on a quand même touché le fond des
parties de droite de gouvernement et de
gauche du gouvernement il y a une raison
que vous n'avez pas à développer parce
que en Suède en effet il y a la montée
de ce parti de de populiste mais et le
Parti social-démocrate et le Parti
Chrétien démocrates à eux ils font 40 %.
donc c'est il faut pas dire que c'est
les pauvrement en effet c'est pas
l'effondrement français et là
l'effondrement français Madame vous
pouvez dire ce que vous voulez mais en
effet comme à Emmanuel Macron ne pas se
représenter il y a pour les journalistes
en effet quelque chose de nouveau
puisque à chaque fois ils se sont fait
battre et là en effet vous allez avoir
pendant 5 ans qu'est-ce qui va se passer
puisqu'il va y avoir forcément une
représentant de la République on parle
de l'Italie il nous reste président
qu'on a à faire d'ici là il nous reste
moins d'un quart d'heure j'aurais qu'on
parle de de l'Italie et je propose à Tam
traduis de nous rejoindre peut-être un
tiens un coup d'œil au sondage dernier
sondage c'était 9 septembre 46% pour la
collection de droite menée par Giorgia
Meloni 27% pour la coalition de centre
gauche voilà à peu près où on est
c'était le 9 septembre donc à 15 jours
du scrutin terme on va
apprendre peut-être parce que je suis
sûr que beaucoup de téléspectateurs ne
la connaissent pas forcément qui est
Georgia Meloni qui pourrait devenir la
première femme chef de gouvernement en
Italie alors c'est la chef du Parti
Fratelli d'Italia frères d'Italie parti
qui est en passe de l'emporter dans le
cadre d'une coalition avec Forza Italia
de l'ex-président du conseil au
Berlusconi qu'on ne présente plus et la
Ligue de Matteo Salvini qu'on ne
présente plus non plus et il faut dire
que la première différence avec
Berlusconi et Salvini c'est que Georgia
Meloni elle n'a pas encore exercé le
pouvoir à vous le disiez Béatrice Giblin
elle sait notamment refusée à participer
au gouvernement d'union nationale de
Mario Draghi ce qui a mis Fratelli
d’italia en position de premier parti
d'opposition au niveau du corpusier
biologique à l'articule libéralisme
économique et conservatisme sociétal
politique anti-musulmans
anti-immigration promotion de valeur
ultra conservatrice fondée sur la
religion et sur la famille
traditionnelle et c'est justement en
affirmant ces valeurs
la matrice ultra conservatrice qui est
devenue célèbre et oui Georgia Meloni
pour les Italiens c'est aussi un slogan
en 2019 elle est déjà installée dans le
paysage politique mais un discours va la
faire complètement changer de catégorie
elle s'oppose alors au revendications
LGBT prononce quelques phrases qui vont
devenir sa marque de fabrique et puis un
hit au sens propre regardé et écouter
[Musique]
vous a fait sourire ces mots remixé ont
donné lieu à une vidéo qui a donc été
virale qui a été visionné 12 millions de
fois sur Youtube qui fait d'elle une
sorte de nouvelle
icône pop et dans la foulée un livre qui
a cartonné et qui s'appelle yossonnot
Giorgia je m'appelle Georgia plus de 160
000 exemplaires en trois mois une
autobiographie où elle raconte son
parcours à la première personne un récit
à la fois intimiste et bien sûr plein
d'idéologie où elle explique comment se
sont forgés ces positions
ultra-conservatrices elle qui a adhéré à
15 ans au front de la jeunesse du
mouvement social italien ce mouvement
c'est l'héritier du Parti national
fasciste de Benito Mussolini et
d'ailleurs elle essaye un peu de gommer
cette partie de son histoire aujourd'hui
oui parce que cette partie de son
histoire elle fait peur elle en a bien
conscience alors qu'elle est pas loin de
l'emporter elle a donc enregistré un
message destiné à rassurer à
l'international écouter ce qu'elle dit
en français
la victoire de fatalital et aux
élections de septembre conduiraient en
désastre en tournant autoritaire à la
sortie de l'Italie de l'Hérault et à
d'autres absurdités de ce genre rien de
tout cela n'est vrai il a plusieurs
décennies que la droite italienne a
relégué les fascismes à l'histoire voilà
pour le discours édulcoré modéré reste
la force de certains symboles le parti
Fratelli d'Italia arbore encore toujours
la flamme chère à la mystique fasciste
comme logo cette même flamme que l'on
retrouvait sur le premier logo du Front
national on va voir les trois logos
s'afficher le premier du Front national
à côté celui du mouvement social italien
dont je parlais à l'instant et puis
celui de Fratelli d'Italia un logo pour
ce qui est du Front national que Marine
Le Pen a fini par complètement effacer
lorsqu'elle a entrepris son projet de
dédiabolisation du parti merci beaucoup
Tam c'était passionnant de découvrir le
parcours de Georgia Meloni Béatrice
Giblin
jusqu'où on peut aller dans la
comparaison avec une Marine Le Pen par
exemple d'après vous
la différence c'est que melonie n'est
pas une héritière avec un père qui avait
fondé un parti et dans laquelle elle a
pu se glisser en revanche il y a
quelqu'un avant melonique et finit et en
fait c'est fini qui est l'homme de MSI
héritier là à ce moment-là directe du
fascisme qui s'est créé juste après la
guerre essentiellement dans le sud de
l'Italie d'ailleurs et
finit il a véritablement fait basculer
ce parti
héritier du fascisme pour un parti qui a
participé au gouvernement il a adoré
être ministre il a été ministre
plusieurs années dans plusieurs postes
et il a vraiment comment fait évoluer
l'image
peut-être pas tout à fait le fond mais
véritablement l'image de ce parti ça
c'est les années ils commencent dans les
années versus connu complètement et ça a
beaucoup joué à ce moment-là avec à
droite quelqu'un qui a occupé l'espace
qui a été la Ligue la Ligue du Nord
dont on parle toujours de Salvini mais
c'est pas lui qui est à l'origine
sachant que dans la Ligue du Nord le
soutien des patrons italiens ce qu'on
appelle petit patron sont pas si petit
que ça d'ailleurs de la Vénitie ou de la
Lombardie était très très important et
ça a été des tremplins extrêmement
importants donc changer mélonie elle
tombe pas comme ça du ciel c'est la même
stratégie de dédiabolisation qu'on voit
l'oeuvre en France en Italie ou dans
d'autres pays vous l'avez très bien
montré alors je rappelle moi j'ai
travaillé sur les symboles en politique
sur les Front national le MSI italien ça
voulait aussi dire mussolin est toujours
vivant c'était la flamme c'était en fait
l'esprit de Mussolini au-dessus de son
cat c'est à dire de ça tombe et son
esprit est toujours vivant c'était aussi
ça que ça voulait dire le Messie pas
seulement Moviemento social italien et
en effet il y a une stratégie de
dédiabolisation mais en même temps ça
continue de s'appeler Fratelli et je
reviens à ce que je disais précédemment
frère d'Italie qui d'autre s'appelle les
frères à part les religieux et à part
les musulmans aujourd'hui dans les
Frères musulmans bien sûr on a les
Frères musulmans et on a les frères
d'Italie on a et quelque part il y a un
combat j'appelle ça
à mon combat religieux on est dans du
politique et du religion on a un mix de
politique et de religieux et Trump ne
fait rien d'autre et bonne sonnaro ne
fait rien d'autre je parlais de maudit
en Inde je parle on peut parler de
Poutine et son église des armée Poutine
mais l'Église à son service il y a
quelque chose en ses débuts du 21e
siècle je sais pas si Malraux l'avait
déjà prédit de retour du religieux le
plus sauvage le plus grégaire le plus
insupportable dans ce qu'il a le plus
politique et le plus dur et quelques
c'est que Marine Le Pen s'appuie pas du
tout là-dessus puisqu'elle a dit pendant
la campagne cela n'est plus un problème
c'est devenu le problème je suis pas
d'accord sur le fait que Georgia et me
ramène le Pen se ressemblent
l'ami de Marine Le Pen sur la scène
politique italienne c'est Matteo Salvini
Matteo Salvini on l'a vu au pouvoir
puisque je vous rappelle que dans la
coalition qu'il a connu à l'intérieur
il a été ministre de l'Intérieur et ça
s'est mal passé là encore une histoire
ou des parties d'extrême droite arrivent
au pouvoir écrit écrit et puis quand il
y a la réalité ça se termine mal on en
appelle à Mario Draghi qui est tout sauf
un homme politique c'est un banquier je
rappelle qui arrive à pacifier tout le
monde et c'est le mouvement de King
postale et la Liga et berlosconi était
pas loin derrière qui a fait exploser le
truc c'est pour ça qu'on a des élections
maintenant et pas en février terme du
truc deuxièmement si Georgia Meloni
arrive aujourd'hui en tête c'est parce
que la gauche a failli en Italie il y a
une collection de droite
avec Fratelli d'Italia qui est le
premier parti de cette coalition la Lega
qui s'appelle plus du Nord d'ailleurs la
Liga toujours Salvini et vous avez celui
qui a gouverné comme l'Italie pendant un
certain nombre d'années etc qui n'est
pas mort à 86 ans politiquement
Sylvie qui est le troisième larron
il est à 7 %. donc ça veut dire que
cette coalition existe à gauche Enrico
qu'on a bien connu parce qu'il a été ici
longtemps à Paris on n'a pas réussi à
faire une coalition et ses anciens amis
du Parti démocrate qui sont partis qui
s'appelle le centre ma théorème
ils ont pas fait de collision donc si
elle gagne c'est parce que aussi en
Italie la gauche et le centre gauche et
tout ce que concerne la gauche à pas
réussi à faire de coalition et donc
c'est une vengeance un petit peu avec
une femme parce que si jamais elle
arrive au pouvoir ça sera vraiment une
première oui ce serait une première dans
l'histoire du pays on l'a dit tout à
l'heure avec moins de 5 minutes ça file
trop vite mais ça prouve que le débat
est passionnant pour parler de des
conséquences sur l'Union européenne et
justement on va entendre Enrico l'état
chef on va dire de l'opposition à
Georgia Meloni secrétaire national du
Parti démocratique italien écoutez son
idée une idée de Europe comme Ligue des
Nations dans lesquelles chaque pays joue
pour lui-même dans lequel les décisions
sont prises à l'unanimité avec le droit
de veto comme Orban veut ou comme Marine
Le Pen veut une idée d'Europe dangereuse
dans mon point de vue parce que l'Italie
de draguer notre Italie l'Italie du
Parti démocrate et en Europe comme
moteur de l'intégration européenne et
l'Italie de Georges de la droite
italienne de Salvini serait en Europe
comme frein voilà une récolta
interviewée par Caroline de Camaret de
France 24 intégralité de cette interview
à découvrir dans l'émission ici l'Europe
qui sera diffusée ce samedi matin 7h30
et puis aussi à 16h30 sur public c'est
najou redonne la parole est-ce qu'on va
vers une Europe encore plus fracturée
avec la Suède et l'Italie
potentiellement il y a déjà aujourd'hui
il faut pas mettre tous ces parties dans
le même sac ils font pas une alliance il
se déteste même les Polonais et les
Hongrois qui sont mis un peu à l'encon
aujourd'hui ne le sont pas pour des
mêmes raisons d'abord il sèche pas dans
les mêmes groupes ils siègent pas dans
la situation politique et pas la même
ils ont des traits communs je suis
d'accord il y a des très commun à tous
ces parties conservateur valeur
chrétiens etc et ils sont rejoints aussi
sur ce sur par le par le fait que les
autres partis dans ces pays à gauche en
gris ont commis des ils ont même ils ont
même reconnu qu'ils avaient fraudé et
qu'ils avaient fait des malversations
donc voilà pourquoi on a Orban c'est
parce que la gauche a fait des maladies
et en Pologne c'est une autre histoire
mais tous ces pays tous ces tous ces
partis ne sont pas au même donc on peut
pas faire une ligne il y a pas il y a
pas une alliance
pour bloquer en effet quand je dis que
ce n'est pas dans le fait de groupe que
Marine Le penche trop vite
excusez-moi il y a quand même quelque
chose qui est qui les rassemble c'est
d'une part qu'ils sont contre l'Union
européenne telle qu'elle existe ça c'est
sûr c'est certain même si son dans les
groupes différents ils ont quand même de
plus en plus de conversation ensemble
ils ont une Internationale des
nationalistes qui fonctionnent bien
notamment sur internet ils ont des
financements qui viennent des États-Unis
ils ne veulent pas en sortir ah non
allez allez chez les Hongrois pour la
faire
exploserait une différence entre les
politiques et les citoyens quand vous
faites des champignons ils veulent tous
rester et ensuite vous pouvez fortement
officiellement ou pas par un certain
Monsieur Poutine qui lui veut qu'il
foutent l'Europe à poil à l'intérieur de
l'Europe je rappelle que les services
les services de renseignement parlent
tous en même temps les services de
remplacement américain ont annoncé je
crois qu'il sortit mardi qui avait au
moins 300 millions de dollars qui
avaient été distribués fait partie des
candidats en
Ukraine c'est à dire que tout le monde a
annoncé une défaite de l'Ukraine assez
rapidement parce que c'était la deuxième
armée du monde avec le soutien des
Américains
que les Russes étaient la deuxième oui
c'était la deuxième armée du monde avec
le soutien on va dire rapidement de
l'Occident mais surtout des Américains
et surtout parce qu'on se bat avec un
sens important qui est la défense de sa
patrie et de sa nation ce qui est pas le
cas évidemment des soldats russes on
verra bien l'histoire est loin d'être
fermée et hongrois qui sont du côté
parce que là ils accueillent mais les
les réfugiés il y en a plus que chez
nous mais qui défendent en effet etc
ils vont tous gagner ils vont tous se
mettre il faut faire très attention il
faut être vigilant mais c'est pas une
famille qui va voilà les barines Le Pen
pour l'instant elle est pas du tout
merci à tous c'est le titre de votre
livre Béatriz Gibelin l'extrême droite
en Europe que vous aviez publié aux
éditions La Découverte demain Oriane
monsini vous donne rendez-vous pour une
émission spéciale puisque la matinale de
Public Sénat sera en direct de Vichy
pour le 18e congrès des régions de
France de rendez-vous notamment entre
autres Renault Muselier président de la
Région PACA Provence 7h30 et puis Carole
Delga la présidente de la région
Occitanie ce sera à 8h belle soirée
salut